en 2016 valérie robichaud bière des
jarres des slows chacun un véhicule pour
une durée de trois ans les deux se
laisse convaincre d'acheter la garantie
protection esthétique qui l'ont payé à
gros prix et ont assisté quand même
beaucoup et en mettant le fait que
j'avais un enfant en bas âge des tanks
et que ça pourrait être bénéfique pour
moi finalement de la prendre pour le
protéger de certains pays
en lisant le contrat on se rend compte
que des exclusions sont nombreuses mais
bien des jardins se sent protégé jusqu'à
ce qu'il remette sa mazda cx-5 à la fin
de son contrat de location l'évaluateur
découvre alors une éraflure dans le
coffre arrière c'est spanc avis c'est à
peine si j'avais même pas remarqué quand
j'ai remis l'auto moore coût de la
facture 412 garantir est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est exagéré
oui c'est exagéré jacques castonguay et
avocats en droit de la consommation
il est d'avis que les compagnies qui
vendent ce type de garantie ont une
façon de faire qui désavantagent le
consommateur donc ont mis sur le fait
que nous répondons promis sur le fait
que vous allez laisser tomber puis vous
allez avaler la pilule puis si vous
n'êtes pas satisfait mais poursuivait
après le retour de sa kia forte valérie
robichaud ne s'attendait jamais à
recevoir une facture de près de 900 $
plus taxes
j'ai eu une tâche sur le tapis qui est
effectué par la peinture la peinture à
l'eau l'évaluateur conclu que la zone
touchée ne peut être nettoyée et qu'il
faut remplacer une portion du tapis
permanent et changer le tapis de surface
ou c'est dommage mais je peux vous et
que je vois ça à tous les jours mais
consomme un temps qu'un parfaitement
raison qu'ils doivent se battre on
valoir leurs droits dans des contrats
souvent pourtant nous avons démontré que
la peinture sur un tapis peut-être
éliminé en moins d'une heure et que le
nettoyage des tapis de madame robichaud
aurait coûté entre 150 et 200 25 dollars
pierre desjardins s'est battu et a
réussi à faire annuler sa facture ce
n'est pas le cas pour valérie robichaud
qui a payé la sienne et qui doit
emprunter le chemin des petites créances
pour tenter de se faire rembourser
ici vivent la montagne radio canada
montréal